hello again welcome to judgment I'm Jean
pyro let's make a deal with the devil
yes Iran has it going on cuz it's got
the world by the tail and the president
under its thumb and I don't want to have
to say Ayatollah do so make a deal with
Iran I'd rather deal with Kanye after a
beck win but I guess it makes sense he
and the president do have a lot in
common they both think they're Supreme
Leader's who can provide healthcare and
resolve international stalemates
whenever they please and what will come
of this diplomatic game of charades one
word two syllables sounds like bale yer
well congressional Republicans won't
lead us quietly into the night they've
sent a letter to iranian officials that
upset some people what's wrong with a
letter just a little something to help
spell out to iran clearly how a
democracy works who knows how they do
things in the islamic republic which way
the toilet flushes does it even flush
who knows if there's even a country
called Iran I can't find it on a map so
who knows if they have enriched uranium
to begin beginning the beginning of the
beginnings of a nuclear weapon remember
every snake is a rattler you just gotta
poke it for a while who needs are on
anyway we've got plenty of friends in
the Middle East as it is Saudi Arabia
Israel and specific us friendly
splinters of particular factions of
certain Syrian rebel groups once we arm
them to the teeth will have an ironclad
coalition for about a week take it from
America nuclear power is for the
privileged few those who understand
strength like the Ferguson Police
Department so yes there is American
exceptionalism get over it it's like an
elevator toot it's shameful until you
realize you can call all the shots and
that's my gaping opening good night and
we're all going to die so the president
wants to close Gitmo and it don't get
most suicidal